here to drive this pawn into d5 in order
to prevent this knife from developing
this gives what a big space advantage i
actually played like this with black
once or twice it's not that bad
but it's certainly not a particularly
good position okay now let's develop our
pieces
knight c3 we could also play c4 uh
expanding our central control but that
would be more
you know we're playing one e4 so this
preserves the spirit 97 okay super
passive play
by black and
he's still not doing anything horrible
but
it's about time we considered reopening
the center but let's not do that just
yet
let's see how he proceeds let's develop
our other knight and then let's see how
he plays because if he plays knight d7
then we'll take on e6 we want to
optimize that moment when we take on on
e6 okay plus h6
so he's really asking for it but
okay so we have a way of playing here
rather than taking immediately
and this concept of trying to find the
best way to execute ideas
is always so important right d take c6
opens up the center
but there's a particular move that we
can start with
which really makes d takes c6 a lot
stronger because de60 can play bishop
takes c6
what am i talking about here it's also a
development move so this move should
come to a lot of you guys just as the
development right bishop b5 check
but it also forces him to cover cover
that check on d7
and then by taking on e6 we do not allow
black's bishop black's bishop is now
pinned it's weird to talk about a bishop
pinning a bishop but
this is a pin in addition that bishop
blocks the queen's contact with d6
which means that after we play dd6 black
is basically busted
if he plays f takes c6 he loses the d
pawn
if he takes on b5 how should we proceed
and there's actually more than one
possibility here
but the sort of thematic move knight
takes b5
there's queen a5 so we always look for
intermediate moves in these positions
we drive this king out and one thing i
want you guys to see
hansel is after knight takes b5 will
queen a5 check win a piece
does quit have we blundered here
yeah no because we can simply go back to
c3 and that's something people sometimes
miss you can block a check
you can block a fork by doing two things
with the forked piece blocking the check
with that very piece
so the he might play queen a5 he plays
queen b6
which is a whole lot worse because now
he gives up another pawn
right and because he's positioned this
that's the the danger of blocking the
development of a piece right
he's positioned the knight very poorly
now he's down two pawns and his position
is in shambles
king and he makes it worse by bringing
his king out to f6
so i'm sure that there's probably many
mates here there's many ways to find
mate
and this process of finding mate is
is not the easiest to describe logically
it's all
it's in many cases a question of pattern
recognition
uh but the first move i think we can
play pretty much automatically
what check do we have i think some of
you guys are saying 98 check i think i
thought about but he
comes back to f7 but we can drive the
king in
into one particular direction yeah i
like the concept of e5 check let's see
where he goes
all right now i see a really pretty idea
which is hard to find i i
can't fully explain why i see it okay i
can't explain how i see it
so first of all we're looking for checks
right fact one is that we're looking for
checks
um and if you look around there might
not seem to be any appealing checks
but that's where people falter i'm not
asking for appealing checks or checks
that your brain might like
let's list them now there's knight g5
trick that's the one that comes to mind
let's consider that for a second knight
you five check well he's gotta take the
knight do we gain anything from that
look around do any of your pieces have
an avenue
to the attack and you could also
think of you could also reverse engineer
this you could want the queen to be
involved as quickly as possible g4 is a
very natural
square right so you could come at it
from the opposite end
i think that's how i did it
subconsciously is i imagined
the target of getting the queen to g4
and that's a devastating
okay so he takes on e5 that's hastens
the demise
now we probably have a mate here
and we could try to find it but if
you're playing like a blitz game
what would be the most efficient move
here who can tell me what would be the
most efficient move in this position
knight c4 wins the queen yeah knight c4
forks the king to the queen
so always keep your eyes peeled for
these kinds of things they can really
help you when you can't find a mate and
you're panicking
things like knight c4 can really make
sure that you're going to win the game
but let me think here
but you know what would be a really cool
move and somebody suggested this move
one move and we're not trying to rub it
in my opponent's face
but we need just maybe one more piece in
the attack
and that'll make them made a lot easier
how can we bring one more piece into the
attack
and what piece should we bring that king
on e5 it can be checked very efficiently
by a rook on e1
f4 is probably possible but i'm thinking
of castling yeah
and what makes this move hard to find
for some people is that it isn't a check
and yet it doesn't have to be right um
his king is so exposed that
who's to say we need to be in a hurry
right okay so
he found a nice move though king f6 but
let's still bring the rook into the
attack rook he won
all right okay so he takes
um and now we can bring the queen into
the game queen f3 check
and uh there's some pretty cool concepts
here actually he's got to go kg6
yeah he's doing a good job escaping this
what do we do now
yeah we can go queen f7 but hey we
didn't bring the rook into the attack
for nothing
let's involve the rook now it seems that
he's escaped but he actually hasn't
and i saw this line so
again i probably didn't made him in the
fastest way but i think this really is
illustrating some of the key attacking
concepts and it's kind of nice
so he has a forced move i don't know why
he's thinking
now we can now this queen can be
repositioned
to f7 by force playing queen f7 is not
the best way to do it though we can go
queen h5
he moves his king then we go queen f7
and now comes the key moment right this
is where a lot of people be like what do
i do now i don't see anything
and the first question that you have to
ask yourself when you
are stumped in this ways can i bring
another piece into the attack
that's oftentimes the solution to these
problems where you
don't quite have enough pieces and
well we have the knight we have the rook
we have the queen that bishop
is pining to get involved and we're now
threatening rook h6 checkmate
because this pawn is pinned by the queen
but that's not the only thing
we're also just threatening to like take
the knight and stuff
we could have also lifted the rook back
and tried to mate him on h3 but this is
the most uh clinical
yeah there's no way to stop the mate i
mean obviously
and you might argue well this is very
one-sided he hasn't brought any of his
pieces in
and when you've got like big boy attacks
okay what's the mate here
if he stops rook h6 it's time to ask
ourselves what squares have been left
behind
what squares are no longer defended
that's another good question and you'll
immediately see g6 that's checkmate
so it definitely wasn't the best
um attacking you know
continuation but for humans it's very
hard to find the fastest mate even for
gm's
and the reason we didn't try to take his
queen is because i'm trying to play very
aggressively that was a nice game
so yeah so e4 c5 we didn't get a chance
to play the smith moro which is c3 you
played e6
and d6 is fine but 97 is
really passive and it occurs to me that
this should be 5 check was possible even
immediately
but how should black play this i mean he
should play knight f6 should develop
normally
or even take on d5 first is is fine and
knight takes d5 knight f6
black is slightly worse but it's nothing
nothing special
right um it's very important to develop
actively he develops passively
and yeah and h6 is really asking for it
so if you're playing black here he has a
very
very clever move here think about what
you need to do in this position you're
really underdeveloped
when you're underdeveloped you don't
want to give your opponent an
opportunity to open up the center so how
should black play
yeah e5 is correct e5 is correct
and that's not a desirable position but
it closes down the center
and you know it makes white's
development advantage less significant
so in a position like this a lot of
beginners would really struggle to find
plans for both sides
but obviously white is still much better
i'm not arguing that white isn't better
but white's advantage is significantly
than yeah the engine move is 92 here
but there's a particular reason for that
and the reason consists of
sort of a high level plan but these
positions are hard to play
yeah you're rerouting the knight
potentially but that's not the main
reason the main reason
is to pave the way for a later f4
um and also to attack the weak pawn
you'll see this plane in the benoni for
example getting the knights of c4 and
then supporting with a4
um and also in the king's indian with
sort of size reversed
yeah anyways um once we played e6 the
game was over
um the game was simply over it was just
completely overwhelming
one second guys
i'll play one more i'm i'm
good with one more
yeah so
once he played h6 the rest is very
straightforward he takes f7 knight takes
b5 he exacerbated him with queen b6
um he exacerbated it with
uh queen b6 and now after takes this is
horrible
and this is just yeah so
yeah so once we played e5 the only the
only uh
sort of highlight here was knight g5
check
and if he would have taken it we would
have played queen g4 and here i would
have played knight c4 i would have won
the queen because we don't quite have
enough pieces to
play otherwise um
and after king e5 this move castles was
was kind of cute right
queenie two check is a mate and seven
according to the computer so the fastest
mate was queenie two
and queenie four forcing him to take the
knight another check with the queen
then a check with the bishop and then
you castle with check
and this is the mate so that's
definitely not
easy to find i mean that's
that involves forcibly getting rid of
the knight to get the king into the d
file but
so yeah rookie one queen f3 rookie six
this is all very fast yeah main and four
okay um it's only slightly faster than
mine yeah castles is not about that's
castle's made in one that's the second
best move
what we did was actually second best
according to the engine so
this is made in nine in exactly in the
way that we played it too
so nice
all right um let's do one more i think
everybody's pretty
clear on the process of attack here
well african bus it's if you know the
definition of a weakness
then you'll know when your opponent is
creating one
yeah queen f3 is a little faster we know
three is made in five
where rookie one is made a nine so i
guess the third best
um so for example when he plays d6 you
already know that this is a weakness
because it's not defended by the e pawn
and it's not defended by the c pawn
it's less about knowing when he's
created a weakness and more about how to
attack that weakness or whether it's
significant
let's play the next game the world and
the wife
880 so we've been playing the karo khan
as a solid
opening choice for a couple of games now
that's not the only opening that we're
going to play
let's see how this guy handles it a lot
of people take here
beginners like to discharge the tension
in the center
but he's like c3 okay so he's playing
playing the main line
all right so let's take this is theory
and now there are three main moves right
there's bishop f5
there's knight d7 and there's knight to
f6 knight to f6
is a very solid move and it's one that
highlights how to play
with a slightly deficient pawn structure
so and it's also very popular nowadays
knight f6 used to be the least popular
of the three
now it's arguably the most popular or
maybe equally as popular as bishop f5 so
f3 by my opponent
he's trying to hold the knight in the
center but that's not a good move
and uh that's not a good move because
it's too early to weaken the king
all right now we can take the knight and
play e5 i'll show that after the game
but because we're playing very solid
chess
let's instead focus on development
now what developing move seems natural
here yeah bishop f5
is very good because we're we're putting
pressure on the knight and developing
our bishop
and one might argue that well why am i
not exploiting the weakness of
created by three it's not about
exploiting any immediate it's not a race
he's going to pay the price for f3 later
all right now we're going to focus on
development
bishop c4 okay so
that's actually an interesting move
because he's allowing us to take the
pawn
but taking the pawn is a little bit
risky from a development standpoint it
opens up the f file
so believe it or not i'm actually not a
huge fan of
up taking on e4 and that's a pretty high
level concept
um and let me write this down
i will expand on this after the game but
the bottom line is i'm a little bit
worried that he's going to get
compensation down the f-file
i would do it in a real game of mine but
we're focusing on development
so instead we're going to continue
developing now this bishop
we're going to blunt by playing e6 but
not immediately
first let's deal with this knight
because if we play e6 and he takes on f6
he might force our queen to come out
early and i don't really like like that
so instead um where should this knight
go
and i'm not giving you guys a big big
choice now bd7
i know some players who are sort of
allergic to putting their knights here
but in the karo khan
it's one of the drawbacks right of
playing c6 is you take the square from
them but this arrangement of knights is
really good knight g5
is is a fine move he's threatening
checkmate
let's not mouselift but now we of course
play e6
to blunt the bishop with the perfect
chance to play e6
all right so
my opponent's intentions are are good
he's trying to
open up the position and attack but he
doesn't have enough pieces in in the
action to do it
so he's just wandering the pawn i mean
d5 is our best defended square
yeah we take toward the center there's
no reason to take with the e pawn or
with the knight we take toward the
center
and we also open up the c file maybe
later we'll want to put a rook on c if
he plays bishop b5 given the type of
player he is
yeah i was gonna say this is likely
and we've had this concept in many games
now if you've done the puzzle battle
and you've done the puzzle rush bishop
is undefended
king is uncastled boom winning the
bishop winning the game
so you'll see people miss this tactic
all the time keep your eyes peeled
specifically for
this tactic specifically for this tactic
because it's missed so often at all
level even at my level it's missed
because it's just not you know it's not
instinctive to look for this kind of
stuff
you don't assume that you can have uh a
game-winning tactic shortly so anyways
um
let's quickly go over that yeah so
knight f6 is called the tartakower
variation after
french russian master seville targauer
was a grand master
i lived a long and sort of adventurous
life
uh and he he's known for a lot of his
like
witty sayings you know like the the
person who wins
is the one who makes the second to last
mistake and all that kind of stuff
so in this position a little bit of
chess history
especially
all right so this position first arose
in 1888
in a game of kurd bombard 11 who lost a
famous game to steinis and the first
people to play this
play bishop f5 the first person to play
knight f6
was caro horatio caro i assume after
from the karaoke on his name but there's
actually
confusingly there's more than one caro
who played the karo khan
but horatio cairo played knight f6 i
think that's whom the karo khan is named
after
and yeah so karo
played knight f6 and he was one of the
earl one of the earliest people to do
that so here's something interesting
guys
horatio caro played knight f6 in 1898
then he played it again in 1905
and the only other person to play it
around that time frame
was aaron nimsevich and the reason that
is the case
in my estimation yeah i think he was
british is because
people didn't want to double their pawns
in the late 1800s right positional chess
wasn't that advanced thank you and it
was only a couple of
people ahead of their time who
understood that there was
more to the picture than just the pawn
structure but if you were joe
you know joe schmoe chess player in the
late 1800s you were taught that
you know the positional chess wasn't
non-existent but
why would you double pawns without any
provocation so nimzovich
who wrote my system was far more
advanced positionally than his peers
so he played that f6 anyways
um i don't want to talk too much about
this we're going to have this many many
times throughout the speed run
but let me explain and you guys already
know
that i've claimed again and again that
pawn structure is
not the most important factor in most
positions
for beginners and intermediate players
and particularly one set of double pawns
in the middle game is
rarely going to be the reason that you
lose the game or the reason that
the evaluation is what it is but in
addition this particular pair of double
pawns is actually very healthy
because this pawn on f6 consider the
pawn
highlighted in in blue and then the pawn
highlighted in
in red well i'm not highlighting a pun
in red or in green
it says to use green this pawn on f6
is controlling these two squares and
then this pawn controls this square
and that's a lot of central squares to
control
and this pawn on f6 is super annoying in
addition there's the concept of
shedding the skin i call this shedding
the skin
um this pawn on f5 let's assume that you
use it as a battering ram right
and you push it all the way to f3 when
my coach first told me this i was kind
of mind blown
even after you do that and even if you
castle short
you're going to be left with a fully
intact kingside pawn structure
so you can often attack in this line
after having castled on the same side
that you're attacking and
not suffer any consequences in terms of
your pawn structure so that's another
team we haven't looked at a single line
yet but i hope i'm explaining some of
the motivation behind it
the theory here is very complex this
line is super popular now
white has even developed some lines
where he castles queenside
which uh wasn't a thing for a long time
so c3 bishop d6
if you watch magnus carlsen games you'll
see this line happen all the time
white quickly piles up on the h-bun
black gives a check white covers it and
this move h5
has seen a resurgence recently it looks
pretty wild but that's kind of what i
mean these pawns offer pretty good
protection for the king
so in term in the event of a castle you
can actually push the spawn at h4 and
use this pawn
in order to weaken white's king's side
galway man thank you for the tier one
so i'm not going to delve any deeper
into this i don't want to bore people to
death
gtx f6 is also a move but this is
considered
significantly more dubious anyways he
plays f3
and uh bishop f5 is our move we also
could have taken
and gone e5 the idea is to open up the
pathway for the queen to h4 so in the
event of
d take c5 queen h4 white is in big
trouble
um and like i said the reason we won't
delve as deeply is because a little bit
later when we get to maybe 13 1400
people will go into the main lines so
we'll talk about the theory then
remember that the motivation here
is to talk about stuff that's valuable
mostly to the rating of which i'm
currently at
so this is also good for black but we
decided to play it solid
and there's a very famous trap where
white plays queen e2
and he threatens checkmate on d6 i'm
sure you guys have seen this before
so here for example we should still play
e6 in order to cover that square
um yeah can you explain the knight d2
versus e6 mover i'm not sure what you
mean
can you can you spell that out yeah so
knight g5 by our opponent e6 and
obviously d5 hastened the demise he
should have just developed his knight
then we could have even played h6 and
this knight is nowhere good to go
and um yeah we're better but
i was going to explain something oh yeah
why didn't i take the pawn
so this is a free pawn and black is
better
but white can play knight f3 here and
white is ahead in development he's
developed two pieces i've developed only
one
and if i go for example e6 and white
quickly castles and guess what white's
already threatening knight g5
and this pawn on f7 could get in trouble
black is two moves away from castling
and these kinds of attacks they happen a
lot faster
than some people realize so for example
if we play bishop e7 thank you benjamin
covering the g5 square how can white
proceed what is the best way to let the
attack unfold here
so it's too early to sack the bishop you
won't have any pieces left
but the move that i have in mind is
knight to e5
also some of you are proposing d5 that's
like the move in the game right this
square is
very well protected by black you're not
going to make this happen
but one of the pieces of advice that i
have and i've shared this from the very
start is not to get fixated
on one particular idea right so if your
opponent has prevented you from doing
something h4 would be too slow
because by the time you get a knight to
g5 black's already castled and this move
has lost its
its luster to some degree instead i
would play knight e5
and i would bring the queen out to g4
i'm not sure this is possible because
black takes the d4 pawn with check
but already you can start considering
these kinds of moves so this isn't that
good
but i'm just trying to show you guys
some of the ways in which this could
have unfolded negatively for black
and i didn't want to allow any of this
given that we're trying to play very
positionally and so that's why i played
knight 87 mr monotone thanks for the
prime
and at this point of course the game
immediately ends after queen a5
does anybody have any questions
about bishop bishop g4 you mean in this
position
where exactly
i'm not sure where you're referring to
why not bishop thinking if you guys are
asking a question
one move prior you mean takes here
oh bishop g5 oh you want to play here
but that's not possible because i can
take your bishop
right i have two defenders on the g5
score one indirectly well one the
x string you're going to blunt out the
bishop carlson
has played this with both sides i think
yeah why isn't king f7 that good
where again if you guys are asking
questions about moose try to be very
specific like at the end of the game you
don't have to tell me the movement
number because you don't know it
but try to be specific as to where in
the game that occurred